ce sont les nouvelles boissons tendance
surtout auprès des adolescents leur
marketing gravitent autour
d'influenceurs américains l'acteur et
boxeur Logan Paul et le rappeur qui est
si en font la promotion sur les réseaux
sociaux
[Applaudissements]
on l'a pas encore bu mais je savais pas
qu'il y avait de la caféine dedans c'est
la toute la confusion si certains
rafraîchissent mon prime ne contiennent
pas de caféine la gamme energy dépasse
quant à elle la quantité de caféine
permet au Canada j'en ai retrouvé dans
mon frigo mais c'était pas c'était pas
avec de la caféine c'est mais on donne
un petit 5 dollars dit oui va t'acheter
quelque chose puis finalement on arrive
avec des produits qu'on que nous-mêmes
on connaît pas selon Santé Canada leur
vente devrait même être interdites au
pays on en retrouve pourtant chez des
détaillants au Québec en Ontario et en
Alberta même la bannière Walmart en
faisait la vente jusqu'à tout récemment
ça peut évidemment amener des
palpitations il y en a qui ont une
histoire de la nausées des maux de tête
à 200 g de caféine la boisson dépasse la
limite autorisée de 180 g une canette
contient l'équivalent en caféine de 3 à
4 expresso et de 6 canettes de cola
évidemment c'est qu'on devient aussi
dépendant d'une certaine façon donc
quand on a quand on n'a pas notre dose
de caféine mais on peut se ramasser avec
des effets de sevrage donc des maux de
tête évidemment de la fatigue une telle
dose de caféine peut même interagir avec
des médicaments comme ceux pour le
trouble déficitaire de l'attention avec
hyperactivité le TDAH
du café comme ça des parents comme Chris
pensent qu'il vaut mieux les retirer des
tablettes oui ça m'inquiète je crois pas
que c'est nécessaire de boire comme la
tasse de café en une dans une baffe
breuvage quand
l'entreprise prime n'a pas répondu à
notre demande d'entrevue
aux États-Unis ou prime Energie répond à
la réglementation en matière de caféine
le breuvage qui cible les jeunes
inquiète la classe politique
de l'État de New York a même demandé
dimanche dernier au secrétariat
américain aux produits alimentaires et
pharmaceutiques de déclencher une
enquête ici Jean-Philippe news
Radio-Canada Montréal